[MUSIC PLAYING]
FULLER: And having been a
visitor here very many times
I've had a great chance to see
life changing-- the pattern,
lifestyles changing
very greatly--
but the environment itself
changing tremendously.
The year that I entered
Harvard, the subway
was completed and opened
from Boston to Cambridge.
And up to this time
been really very--
well, MIT could get over
of Boston quite rapidly.
But MIT-- much of it had
been in Boston in those days.
Because when I was young I felt
the great change was taking
place that had not
been experienced
by my father, my
grandfather, all the family
records that I had--
I thought it might
be a good idea
to keep some record of
a little individual born
in the Victorian period
and who is coming over
in some kind of new world.
And so I have kept
just such records.
And I have really,
really large archives.
And they're down in
Philadelphia right now.
But by virtue of having them
I'm able to look at records,
they're changing things, and
get a sense of rates of change
and have some sense of
what may be unfolding
for humanity on our planet.
I think it great fun.
I was seven when the first
automobile came into Boston.
I was eight when the Wright
brothers' first flew.
I was brought up as inherently
impossible for man to fly.
Those were impressionistic
years up to eight years of age.
And wireless-- how
crazy can you get?
Even though Marconi had
invented the wireless the year
that I was born, we
don't have an SOS
till I'm 12 years of age.
And so these were
very extraordinary,
and that was things that
were suddenly becoming,
and many things that I've
been told would never happen
were beginning to happen.
I was told man and never
got to the North Pole,
never got to the South Pole.
And when I was 14 they
did get to the North Pole.
When I was 16, got
to the South Pole.
So there's something
that was happening here
that all the world had
not expected that's all.
That's all I'm trying to get at.
So I felt really very
intuitive to this necessity
to keep some kind of
record of the transition.
I'm sure it's only because I'd
did start doing that years ago
that you've invited
me to be here tonight.
Because I have been
able to keep some track
and been able to make
some pregnostications
that have come true.
But I don't think there's
ever been a moment our humans
on our planet--
by humans have really come to
know so much about our planet
and about the local
universe, where
humans have ever been in such
perilous we really are today.
I think we're absolutely on
the brink of either doing away
with ourselves.
And all of this
then relates to--
I wonder if it'd be possible for
me to have a chair brought out.
I should have asked
for it in advance.
I have podia-phobia.
I don't normally get
behind these things.
[LAUGHTER]
I think I'll think better
if I'm sitting down.
Because I operate entirely
what I call thinking out loud.
Thank you very much.
At the age of 32 in 1927--
which is the year
that Lindbergh flew
across the Atlantic-- which is
suddenly a great change again,
that human beings not
only were now flying,
but they would be able
to cross great oceans.
At the age of 32 then I decided
to really make an experiment
with the rest of my life--
trying to find out
what, if anything,
a little penniless,
unknown individual might
be able to do effectively
on behalf of all humanity,
the great nations and
great corporations
inherently could not do.
So I was just fairly
simply, think about this--
luckily I'd been in the
regular United States Navy
and I'd had some commands.
And so I could think about the
fact that 3/4 of earth is water
and the Navy was concerned with
that 3/4 the world is water.
Out of the 1/4 that is
dry land, about half it
is covered with
ice, rocks, deserts.
So then only about 1/8
of the surface of earth
but propitious for life support.
And that 1/8 is invited up
into well over 100 nations,
at the time I decided
to do my experiment.
So a 100 nations
dividing up 1/8--
each one of them tending
to look out for its own.
It was so much pioneering
of humanity got it so far.
She continually found herself
being attacked by others.
People in America had
a little more luck
because they were further
away from the others.
Anyway, quite
clearly those nations
were thinking about
their fraction of the 1/8
of the surface of the Earth.
And the great corporations were
operating under the protection
of the various nations.
And they had to make profits
at a short period of time
or they go out of business.
At least that's the
way they thought.
So they were inherently
shortsighted.
And so there was nothing--
and nobody was thinking
about our total planet
as a ship-- a spaceship.
Incredibly designed, and
onboard of it all these humans.
And by this time a
radial accumulated
knowledge, great
identification of resources.
So I said there's
nothing to stop me
as little individual
thinking about then,
this total Spaceship Earth.
I gave it that name after a
while and it became popular.
And nothing to stop
me then of seeing
about how to employ
the total knowledge
of the total resources to
take care of all humanity--
paying absolutely no attention
to any kind of divisions
of the human beings, but trying
to look at it as all humans.
I wondered why the
universe to have humans
on board in the universe
and have them on board
this little particular planet.
I found that the more
I studied human beings
in contradistinction
to other organisms,
the more I was convinced we had
some very important function
to fulfill here in the universe.
And the universe
had no supercargos--
that everything that
was in the universe
was essential to the
integrity of the regeneration
of universe.
So the function-- I'll come
down to it very rapidly--
differentiating between
humans and other organisms.
I said all the other
living organisms
have some built in integral
equipment in the organism
itself that gives
it special advantage
in some special environment,
whether kind of snout on a dog
to be able to dig
from the ground,
or some little vine that just
could grow up the Amazon--
and do it very beautifully.
Or birds flying in the
sky with beautiful wings,
but when non-flying unable
to disencumber themselves
of their wings because
they're integral,
if walking is a difficult
matter for the bird.
So I said humans
then, don't have these
built in special equipments.
A lot of people identify
brain with humans,
but there are many
creatures have brains.
And I've found that if
you want to think about it
in your own direct experience--
brains are always and only
coordinating the information
of the senses,
without which we are
utterly unaware of universe.
So they're coordinating
the special cases.
This one smells a little
different than that one.
So we have packages
of these special case
experiences which brains are
able to store and retrieve
memory of.
I've found humans have a
special capability that
are not manifest by any other
creature, which I call minds.
Because I heard mind and
brain inter-exchanged,
but I'm now
differentiating clearly--
brains is physical equipment
for coordinating the senses.
And mind-- from time to time--
had the capability to discover
relationships existing
between special
cases that were not
manifest by any of
the special cases,
considered only by themselves.
As for instance, the
long extraordinary case
of human beings being
excited by the night sky,
all seemingly fixed eyes,
recognizable constellations.
In contradistinction
to which they were one,
two, three from
time to time, lights
that appeared a little bit
brighter than the others.
And you could see them
moving against things,
but tonight they're in different
position from yesterday.
So quite clearly, they
were moving around--
What later on we begin
to call the planets.
And these were so
intriguing to humanity
that they made all
kinds of speculations.
They kept records
out of them as best
they could in relation
to their periods
as seasons and
other experiences.
And they gave them
names of gods.
But not until human beings
have calculated capability,
which is really very,
very recent as far
as humanity in general goes--
which came along
with the positioning
of numbers and the ability
then to multiply and divide.
If you ever tried doing your
calculations in Roman numerals,
you find how difficult it is.
In fact, you can't
get anywhere at all.
So not until then these
Arabic numerals came in
and the cipher itself,
and they got publication
in northern Africa in 1200.
Then it took 300
years for it to get
into Italy and southern
Germany, the point where
Copernicus, as a human being,
has calculated capability.
And with calculating
capability and taking the data
regarding what we knew of these
planets and the sun in the sky
was that we're one of those
planets going around the sun.
The sun was not going around us.
I want to really stress
how very, very recent
is that event
because I find today,
though it was 500 years
ago, we're really not--
and everybody knows about it--
we have done very little to get
ourselves actually celebrating,
reacting in terms of it.
For instance, I
had a great honor
of being invited to speak
to the MIT Faculty Club
back in the early '50s.
And the dean of architecture
at that time was--
said to me that he found that
the Architecture Department was
never being asked to give any
Faculty Club talks because MIT
felt that it's so really
MIT that the Architecture
Department was sort of
a department of liaison
with idiots.
[LAUGHTER]
So they were not really
taken very seriously.
So he complained to the
other deans about it.
And they said, all right, you'll
have the next faculty lecture.
And so the dean asked
me to give the talk.
And because I knew about
his saying about the fact
that the family
liaison was idiots,
I said to the Faculty
Club when I stood up
I was very surprised to be asked
to speak to them because they
were all so ignorant.
And they looked very
surprised, and I
had to make good in a hurry.
[LAUGHTER]
And I said, of
any of you present
who do not see the sun going
down in the evening, please
show your hands.
There were no hands.
I said you've had 500 years.
You've known the sun is not
going down for 500 years.
What are you doing in
your educational system
about coordinating your
senses with your information?
[LAUGHTER]
I think it's very ignorant
to persist in this manner.
Keep on saying you're
very practical to say
sunrise and sunset.
Seems to be rather good poetry,
but you keep continually
standing your kids off
with misinformation.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, that is enough of that
particular episode, but I--
[LAUGHTER]
Coming back now to trying
to identify humans.
And I said we have
this phenomena mind,
and we have this
matter then of planets.
The idea suddenly that we're
one of the planets going
around the sun.
And this is enormously
intrigued others.
And we have Tycho Brahe
getting better instruments,
being a man of great means,
and making some better
observations.
He needs a mathematician,
getting Kepler.
And Kepler then discovering
that all these different planets
were a different distance from
the sun, all different sizes,
all going around
at different rates.
So while they're all
on the same team,
seem to be very disorderly.
But being a
mathematician, he said,
I know one thing
in common, which
is they're going around
the sun, at least that.
I could, as a
mathematician, give them
something else in common.
I might be able to find
radium with two knowns.
So he said, I'm going
to give them a known.
He said, I'm going to
give them so many days.
As I remember, it was 21 days.
And giving them exactly 21
days, right to the second,
he knew where each
one was in respect
to the sun or the stars.
He'd know the
distances from the sun.
By this time, he discovered
the moving in elliptical arcs.
So he then had the radius
from the sun or the stars
and then a different radius--
a little different radius
at the end of the 21 days.
And he knew actually then.
He was able to make a diagram
of each one of these new radius
and the elliptical arc.
And having these pictures
now of triangles-- long,
thin triangles--
he said, I have all the data.
I might as well
calculate these areas.
Well, there doesn't seem
to be any sort of triangles
in the sky.
Might as well do that.
And if you were Kepler and
then make this calculation
and discover they
were not similar,
but they were exactly the same,
think of it-- the astonishment
of a human being that
hidden in this great soup
of this disorder was an elegant
mathematical coordination.
Because obviously it was
coordinated to come out
exactly the same-- all of them.
So that you then have
to think in a way
that you and I have never
have, and no other human being
has ever had to think before.
Because he doesn't tell
you this in his diary,
but supposing they were
touching each other,
he might understand
how they might
move like gears to coordinate.
But they were millions
of miles apart.
Millions of miles
apart, and human beings
had no idea of
anything operating
in millions of miles apart
in a tension and absolutely
invisible-- some kind of
invisible tendon operating it.
Think of it.
Think of the intellectual
challenge that really was.
But he was familiar,
as a human being,
that if you swing a
weight around your head,
it stays in orbit.
If you let go, it
goes off in a line.
Also he has familiar, if you
wanted to make an ellipse,
you have to use two restraints
instead of one restraint.
So he had to assume
somehow or other--
because he had found them
moving elliptically--
that there was some
kind of restraints
of tensions operating
over millions of miles.
And the fact that the planets
bunched from time to time
may then possibly pull on--
the bunch could pull on the
one, as well as the sun.
And he made those kind
of ordinary discoveries.
Now, here we have suddenly
some interrelationship existing
between that does not
manifest in any one of those.
Nothing-- not any
one planet that
said there could be
strings to another planet,
as you'll get out of what
I'm talking about it.
Because there was a
group behaving this way
that humanity never
paid attention.
And finally when a
team behaving a little
differently from all the
rest of the universe,
it finally discovers some
relationship going on there.
We go on from there
to Galileo measuring
the rate of falling
bodies, acceleration
of the rate of
falling, and getting
the mathematics of that.
And we have Isaac Newton
tremendously eager
to understand what this
extraordinary, invisible
tension was that Kepler
had now discovered.
And have Isaac
Newton then finally
being able to work out the fact
that the interrelationship,
the interattractiveness,
was varying
as a second power,
mathematical distances apart,
but the inverse ratio of it.
That is, if you halve the
distance between the two,
you increase to one-,
two-, four-fold.
If you doubled the
distance apart,
it went down one
quarter of it before.
Suddenly, we then
have a human mind
able to discover the
mathematical relationship--
which, firstly was hypothetical.
But then as it's tested,
and tested, and tested back,
astronomers are always
explaining the interaction
of these celestial bodies--
whatever bodies you're studying.
So this rapidly
became what we call
a mathematical generalization--
a scientific generalization--
and found no
exceptions whatsoever.
And it could only be
expressed mathematically.
So suddenly we
find the human mind
having a capability from time to
time to discover a relationship
existing between which can only
be expressed mathematically.
It's a highly intellectual
matter, and we have then--
I said brain dealing
in the special cases.
And then the special
cases were always
temporal-- had
beginnings and endings.
And what we have suddenly--
the human mind discovering
these principles.
And as I say, if they qualify
as a generalized principle,
it means they have
no exceptions.
And that which has no exceptions
must be inherently eternal.
Nothing to say that one
of these generalizations
may not someday prove
to have exceptions.
But as far as we know, there
is a family of them today
which we have no exception.
Therefore, up to the time
we find the exception,
it must be considered
as inherently eternal.
And that's very different.
The human brain then asking
for beginnings and endings
of the universe,
and the human mind
having capability to discover
that which is eternal.
I became very intrigued
then by the idea
of what we call behaviors
of whole systems
like the planetary systems,
solar system, in which
the behavior of the
whole is not explained
by behavior of any of the powers
considered only separately.
We call that synergetic.
So then I began to think about
the universe in those kinds
of terms and saying, how many
of these generalized principles
have we discovered?
As we discover
one, we don't know
we're going to discover it,
but suddenly we have it.
Nor do we know
whether it's going
to be the last one that
would ever be discovered.
We don't know how
many there are.
But there is an
increasing inventory
There's a principle
of leverages,
the mathematics of that.
And as Galileo
showed, you didn't
have to have a compression
lever and compression fulcrum.
You could have a
tension fulcrum.
You could have pulleys,
and falls counting out
the same mathematics.
So they are beautiful
mathematical laws
which are generalizations
that human beings could use
objectively as special cases.
That then gave me an
odd feeling that humans
had a very different kind
of function in the universe.
Because we didn't know
any other phenomena
that had access to these
extraordinary generalized
principles.
Because when you and
I use the word design,
we immediately would infer
an intellectual sorting and
deliberate arrangement.
In other words, the
word design seems
to involve a complex of
that which is to be sorted
and to be arranged.
And the best we can see,
then, these human minds
have been discovering these
generalized principles.
And I said, what is very
impressive about them
is not only are they being
eternalized-- they're
all concurrently
operative-- but none of them
has ever been found to
contradict any of the others,
and several of them
are augmentative.
So in sum totally, a fine
human mind apparently
being admitted to some
of the great design
of the universe itself.
I said, we must
be very important
if we have kind of access.
Therefore, we are now
trying to understand
why we're bound to this
planet and, we're thinking,
bound to the universe itself.
I also want you to think
about the extraordinary change
in the phenomena concept
of universe just in my day.
When I was 28, Hubble
discovered another galaxy.
Pretty extraordinary.
And we called it galaxy because
we had our galactic Milky
Way, our galactic system.
And so there's another galaxy.
And today, we know of
2 billion galaxies.
So this will give you
an idea of the rate
of expansion of what you and I
have to consider as universe.
But you spontaneously today
think about the universe
as vastly greater than anything
I had to think about as.
Universe And this will
give you, again, a sense
of the great,
incredible acceleration
of knowing that's taking
place with humanity itself.
Now, thinking about that,
this function of humans
in the universe,
I also said, one
of the things that's
very impressive
is that human beings are
all born, always born,
naked, absolutely helpless for
months, beautiful equipment
but absolutely ignorant
because no experience.
So that we're deliberately
born that way,
even though as our
eyes are designed,
our brain's designed
with a quadrillion
atoms in coordinates, and
you and I can communicate.
That's all a priori.
And so it's extraordinarily dumb
that we take it tremendously
for granted.
And it's only very
recently we begin
to really take some kind
of cognizance so the fact
that this is such incredible
technology that we don't even
call it technology, because it's
way beyond the kind of grasp
that humans so far
have of technology
and the kind of principles
we've employed up to date.
Now-- thinking now,
from this point on,
I'm trying to identify why
humans are in the universe
and what we might be able to do
about carrying on abetting what
nature, our universe-- why
does the universe have us
here, and trying to abet the
realization of that function.
In view of the
fact we are always
born naked, helpless, and
ignorant, and the relatively
short time we know of
our being on board here--
for about 3 million years.
It is amazing to me how
human beings then being
born naked, helpless, ignorant,
but hungry, thirsty, curious,
driven to make moves.
Hungry, trying out this.
And somebody eats a
berry, and they die.
For then 1,000 years, that tribe
said nobody can eat berries.
And then suddenly it discovered
there's some berries you can
eat, some you couldn't.
And nature didn't have
any operating manual.
She could perfectly well
have had green safe to eat
and red dangerous to
eat if she wanted to.
But she didn't do it that way.
She deliberately forced us
to learn by trial and error.
That seemed to be a
deliberate part of the design.
So that we've had to make an
incredible number of mistakes
in those 3 million
years or more.
And we've gotten
now to a point where
we have discovered so many--
150,000 nuances of
experience, which
is so unique that they
require their own words,
and we've agreed on those words.
It's amazing matter
we've agreed that much,
because agreements
are very different.
So I found that here we
have an enormous facility
of communication
with one another.
And we suddenly have
come to a point where
we did get that communication.
And we then began to accumulate
information very, very rapidly.
And I felt that all
of this had to do
with all of us being born
in this sort of group
womb of permitted ignorance,
with an enormous amount
of resources by which we
could, by trial and error,
learn something about why
we're here in the universe.
And to me, then, is the most
absolutely important thing
about us is our minds.
Clearly, our muscle is nothing.
We can't compete with a donkey.
And we mean to get to
thinking about the energies
in our universe that makes for
a rather quick summary of two
things.
As we know, during my lifetime
and just in this century,
we began to discover that
chemical elements have
unique frequencies
when incandescent
in an arc frame which could be
detected by the spectroscope.
And we have now,
using the light coming
from the 2 billion
galaxies, we've
been able to take that light and
run it through a spectroscope.
And on one of our planets,
little human beings
have an inventory of
the relative abundance
of all the chemical
elements present within 11
and 1/2 billion light
years around us.
The human mind can has that
kind of scope and capability.
But a muscle?
Nothing.
And yet muscle and
cunning are still
in control of human affairs.
So this is right why
we are in great peril.
Because we're here quite
clearly for our minds, and minds
are not in control.
Now, I would come back to some
things that hit me very hard
and are of great significance.
For instance, in the Navy, where
I had been commander of a ship,
and I had been so taught
that I could take over
the job of my senior.
I could take over the ship,
or I could take over the fleet
if necessary.
The whole training was that
way, all leading up to a moment
of contact and destruction.
I wondered how and why all
this extraordinary technology,
beautiful science
had been reduced
as to work to destruction.
And this brought me,
then, to the discovery
of the fact that for up to
1500, we'd been really thinking
about all the universe
as a flat universe,
even though there were
individuals who were quite
sure our world was a sphere.
But that was
anything but popular.
The general way of
thinking about it
was having a flat Earth.
The Ptolemaic map, going
back really 3,000 years,
was fitting.
It took in all of Europe,
North Africa, and Asia
in sort of a rectangular form.
Then came to the wilderness
and went on to infinity.
But it was a flat world.
Now, this is true of
all the great empires--
of Charlemagne, the Roman
Empire, you want anyone--
Genghis Khan-- all
of those empires
were these flat empires
going to infinity.
And if you didn't like
the way things are,
there are an infinite
number of gods
and an infinite
number of chances
that you'd come out all
right if you prayed.
So it was worth praying.
And we have suddenly
Magellan and discovering
we're on a spherical earth.
And we have the most powerful
people of these times,
and learned that what we call
the control of the world wealth
was by virtue of the controlling
of the great waterways.
I'm going to-- I'd like
to extend that a little,
because you are MIT.
And we have the
archaeologically the city-state
being discovered over and over
again-- in great walled cities.
Mycenae in Greece is
a good example of it.
There's a beautiful,
fertile valley, great rung
around the mountains.
In the middle is
a great high hill.
And then on that high hill, you
could see all the passes coming
into it, and you could look at
all the great fertile fields
and command the whole show.
And then you have, by
building great walls
around the top of
that hill, and then
walls going down to the well,
you had a very safe citadel.
When you saw an enemy
coming, you then
took all the foods
from the valley
and brought them inside
the walls if you could.
What you couldn't
bring in, you'd
do what they call a scorch.
You burn them up.
So when the enemy came
in, all the local people
had all their food inside,
and they had all their water.
The people who came
were already hungry,
and they could undergo
30 days without food
without getting very, very weak.
And then when they
get good and weak,
you can go out
and decimate them.
And this is why
the city-state was
a very successful intervention
for thousands of years.
In the meantime, human
beings began to build--
well, 3/4 of Earth
is covered in water.
Going from just
dugouts and rafts,
and to suddenly getting
to ribbed ships.
And the ribbed ships
got bigger and bigger,
and got to the point of
about the time of Mycenae,
or even Crete.
And the Island of Crete,
there's no fortification,
because this is the headquarters
of the water people.
There's bigger and bigger boats.
And we have then the Myceneans
going in their big boats
up to Troy.
And Troy, commandingly the
traffic from Asia into Europe--
it was an extraordinarily
important point--
complete with a walled city.
So they have all
their food inside.
When the enemy comes,
they expect the people
outside to starve.
But suddenly, there
were these great ships.
They could go off and
get more supplies,
continually brings supplies up.
This is what we call
a line of supply.
And then Troy fell.
And then, from this
point on, history
begins that where the great
and powerful people control,
and the biggest control
is from controlling
great lines of supply.
This shows up very much when you
get to Italy, where you see all
those beautiful, fertile
valleys with lovely castellos
commanding the valleys.
But there's one city in
Italy that's very different--
Venice.
And no walls whatsoever
because they're water people.
And the water people then took
their ships all around Italy
and brought up lines of supply,
and they starved all the people
out of the castellos.
This was a great change over in
the fundamentals of humanity.
So we have suddenly Magellan
going around the world.
And those who control the great
lines of supply between Europe
and Asia, who has enormous
resources, great wealth
had already been developed to
bring that wealth to Europe
and cash in on it.
Enormous ambitions to do that.
These ambitions are
operated under the names
of different countries
like France and Portugal,
but they're really great,
powerful individuals.
Queen Elizabeth I founds
the East India Company
in 1600, about 3/4 of a century
after Magellan gets around.
It was a private enterprise with
some of her private friends,
and she was able to protect it
with her empire's capability.
There's enormous battles.
And by the Battle of
Trafalgar in 1805,
suddenly British empire is it.
And it's said to be the first
empire on which the sun never
set.
In order to carry on
and develop that empire,
they also developed, then,
the East India Company College
in England, which
is still there.
The campus is still operating--
very beautiful campus.
And on that campus in 1800,
writing just before Trafalgar--
five years before and five years
after, two different books--
you have Thomas Malthus, who
is a professor of economics
at the East India
Company College.
And he is the first
individual in history
to have total vital statistics
from around a closed system
earth, because the East
India Company contacts
all these servants all
around the world picking up
the critical information.
So suddenly, he has this
incredible information,
and he's able to write 1800,
and then 1810 to confirm it.
And quite clearly, humanity
was multiplying itself
at a geometrical rate,
producing life support only
at an arithmetical rate.
And quite clearly, the
majority of humanity's
designed to be a failure.
Pray all you want.
It won't do any good.
This isn't as it is anymore.
So this is very formidable
piece of information
for those who are in the know.
But there was a
general illiteracy.
It was not a popular
piece of knowledge
at all as the
information of those
who were in powerful positions
making very critical decisions
for humanity.
We have then, 35
years later, Darwin
promulgating his
theory of evolution
and suggesting that
survival only of the fittest
is the fundamental cause of it.
Then we have the economists
saying, all right.
We like that.
But Darwin said, I did not
develop this in economics.
I did not mean it.
But the economists said, well,
it fits our case perfectly.
Then we have Karl
Marx in English
saying he now accepts
Malthus as pure science,
as a closed system.
It's a closed system--
hard fact.
And we have Darwin, survival
only of the fittest.
So Karl Marx said quite
clearly, the worker
is fittest survive
because he knows
how to handle the tools
to make all the products,
how to grow the
seeds and things.
These other people
are parasites.
The other people said, we're
obviously not parasites.
We're at the top of the
heap because the workers
are so dull, we need some really
bright people around here.
Make some kind of long distance,
visionary speculations.
So we have then, since
that time, a closed system
Earth instead of a flat Earth.
Rather, suddenly
instead of being
a dichotomy of different
kind of religions,
we have the socialist
and the viewpoint
and the out and out enterprise.
There's various degrees
between the two,
but we have since that
time on our planet,
the great ideologies
saying you may not
like our system
personally, but we're
convinced we have the
fairest, most logical,
most ingenious way of coping
with vessel inadequacy of life
support.
But because there are those
who disagree diametrically
on how to cope, it can only
be resolved by trial of arms.
Which system is
fittest to survive?
And that's the
reason, for instance,
that Russia and the United
States for the last 30 years
have been appropriating
over $200 billion a year--
sum total now over $6 trillion--
have been appropriating,
so buying the highest
capability of humanity
and focus it on how to
destroy most accurately, most
effectively, at greater and
greater distances, swifter
and swifter.
This seems like an incredibly
poor investment of all
that we've really
learned, then, right?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: That's where it's gone.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
FULLER: I'm worried about time.
I'm trying to think
how to get everything
I really need to get to in the
shortest numbers of minutes.
Anyway, what I had begun
to experience-- as I said,
here I am in Cambridge
as a little boy,
and I'm suddenly having
this wireless come in,
suddenly the
airplanes coming in.
I said, I really feel something.
And what was really
coming in was from what
I call a visible reality.
Reality, when I was
young, was everything
you could see, smell,
touch, and hear.
That's reality.
And they said, if you're a
sane man, and you're healthy,
you knew just what you're doing.
Suddenly, this is
upset very much
by Freud and Mesmer discovering
a great many things we
didn't know, but we're
still doing them anyway.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: But when I was young, it
was really exactly what I sad.
You knew just what you're doing
if you can smell it, touch it,
see it, and hear it, can't you?
Now, I realized something
was coming in which
I call an invisible reality.
Because suddenly, when I
was three years of age,
electrons were discovered.
It didn't make any newspaper.
Nobody knew that's
going to be anything.
And suddenly there
were these alloys.
And we're suddenly bringing,
by really accident--
all the great alloy
discoveries by metallurgists
have been really accidental
up to the time of the space
program after World War II.
And so we had, them, alloys.
And an alloy--
I'll just give you in
terms of aluminum, which
is very dramatically clear.
Aluminum is where we learned
to refine electrolytically only
in the '90s, but we
don't really use it
for anything but a souvenir,
as ashtrays, and things
like that up to the
1930s when it goes
in the airplane for first time.
And the aluminum,
and what we use
as the obvious property
giving the greatest
clue to the strength
of material,
is the ability to go here
and not be pulled apart.
And so we call it a tensile
strength per square inch
or whatever section we want.
And so the tensile
strength of pure aluminum
is 18,000 pounds
per square inch.
We learned then, accidentally--
a little copper got
into and so forth--
and it got up suddenly to
double that strength of 36,000.
Then during World
War II, the Japanese
brought in another
alloy that got up
to 72,000 pounds
per square inch.
So I could have three
rods of aluminum
here, one inch in diameter,
say three feet long, all
the way the same.
No scientists can look at them,
tell any difference whatsoever,
and this one is double of
this, and this is double again.
Now, here was something
coming into World War I
that I, being a
regular line officer,
became tremendously aware of.
And up to this
time, everybody knew
that spies could see the size
of the ships they were building.
It took a long time
to build a ship.
You could take, then,
the total cubage
of the weight of that
water, that cubage of water
was all the ship could weigh,
everything had on board.
But suddenly, I saw in World War
I that a ship is coming at you
and has the same
tonnage as your ship,
has the same number of
guns, the same size guns.
But yet, this you
don't know, and it's
coming at you, that its metal
is much stronger in the front,
and it can fire
much further away.
And this became the most highly
classified secret information
in World War I, was the alloys.
And suddenly we had
an invisible reality.
And the public
couldn't tell about it.
It's very easy to keep a
secret in complete ignorancy
and no way to understand.
So one ship went to the bottom,
of they couldn't tell anything
about it.
And so it is very easy
keeping that kind of secret.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: So I became
fascinated, then,
in World War I to
realize that we're
beginning to do more with
the same and more with less.
And I could see it was coming
in many different ways.
In electronics--
Malthaus didn't know.
He assumed if you had a message
to go across the Atlantic,
you had to send a ship.
It was going to
take 40, 50 days.
He didn't know I had a
little piece of apparatus.
that I could do it at
186,000 miles a second.
I said, how many things
did Malthaus leave out?
So I began to keep lists of it.
By 1917, really late 1917,
I'd become really excited
to realize there was something
going on in humanity which
had me intuitively
curious anyway,
where we're doing more
with less invisibly.
And might be someday that you
do so much with so little,
it might be possible
that Malthaus was wrong.
It might be enough for everybody
if we did it enough of it.
This was a terribly
challenging idea
as a kid to really get in
to see it could be true.
I came out of the Navy and
went into the building world.
I stayed in that building
world for five years,
and I found it
thousands of years
behind the arts of the
environment controlling
of the sea and the sky.
I just wanted to point out, too,
how you talk about how much--
you know exactly what a
Boeing 747 weighs, loaded--
three tons-- and her rate of
climb, how many people she
can carry.
You know everything she can do
out of every pound of material
you put in, every ounce of
materials, every erg of energy,
every second of time.
But you ask if you people
what buildings weigh,
they don't know what
the buildings weigh.
If you don't know
what buildings weigh,
you certainly don't have
any way to ratio performance
or just want to get an
idea of the building world
on the land being thousands
of years behind that
of the sea and the sky.
We know exactly what you're
getting out of every ounce.
You have to know.
So I became excited to realize
that it was in the building
world that we're really
behind, because there
was something called priorities
in relation to the military.
If these heads of
state, then, are
going to have to
protect themselves
against other states, they're
going to defend themselves.
There's not enough to go around.
They've been told that.
Then they leave things to
the military to defend them.
The military will
say, well, all right.
We now know that there are
these chemical elements.
And there's so much mercury,
and there's so much helium.
And they do something
absolutely unique
that nothing else could do.
Who has access to these
absolutely unique, high
performance materials?
Who has access to the
unique, very high performance
of special instruments and
tools, production tools
made by well-trained brains?
Obviously, then, you
have priority of access
to the high performance
capabilities.
The military had that.
This meant then that
if you have priority,
you have to have anti-priority.
Who has to make do with the low
performance or no performance
at all?
It was obviously the home front.
There's not enough
for people anyway.
Let the poor devils get
on the best they can.
So human beings
being human beings
and trying to make
the best of life,
did get up in architecture
that was, to them, at least
attractive out of the make do.
Where we have then the bigger
heavier, the thicker the wall,
more secure.
That idea went out
in architecture
along with the Maginot Line.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: And right up to then,
you consoled yourself that way.
The bigger, and
heavier, and higher
the walls, the more secure.
We used to have all
the advertisement
when I was young about a
great insurance company
with, Safe as the
Rock of Gibraltar.
They don't use that
advertisement anymore.
No.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: Now, what
excited me in 1927--
I'd been in this
building world and found
that no scientists
ever had even been
asked to look at the plumbing.
Just think of it.
No scientist has ever done
anything about the plumbing.
You have beautiful
courses here on frictions
in pipes and things
like that, but nobody
is redesigning the plumbing.
Here we have the human
beings, every one
of you, several times a day
taking this beautiful sun
evaporation, water getting
in the sky and coming down
and absolutely pure to us.
And we take that
beautiful water,
and we use four and five
gallons several times a day
to get rid of a pint of yellow.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: How much
sense does that make?
And they'd just
say, the home front
was absolutely
thousands of years
behind the art of
the sea and the sky.
So in 1927, the American
Institute of Architects,
as they do today,
had their journal.
And in their journal,
they published
buildings they thought well of.
And they had a single
family dwelling in Illinois
in 1927 which they
thought was optimum
for under the
conditions of 1927.
I took that total floor area,
total cubage, total number
of windows and lumens of light
that could get in, everything
it had equipment to do,
listed all the performance
capabilities.
And I took its total weight,
including the pipes out
to the mains.
It came out 150 tons.
Then having to match the
same cubage, same floor area,
every performance capability
of the single family
dwelling, Illinois, but using
the most advanced aircraft
design of the time, it
came out only three tons.
So I said, three
tons against 150.
If we really began,
instead of waiting,
which was going
on in those days.
I saw after the military
developed something,
then suddenly it
became obsolete.
They had to take the
weapon, and people
who were all tooled up to
produce this kind of equipment,
then look around the home
front for some outlets.
This is how the process
of the refrigeration which
it had in the navy
for 25 years suddenly
came up on the land in
the '20s, and suddenly you
didn't have to have
ice in your box there.
And so I saw
there's fallout that
came very secondarily,
very laggardly,
maybe a quarter of a century,
maybe half a century later,
came into the home
front and began
to change the
standard of living.
In the terms of
which, yes, in my day,
we've gone from less
than 1% of humanity
to 56% of humanity enjoying
a higher standard of living
today than was known or
expected by any potentate when
I was born.
And during that time, we've
doubled the population--
so actually have 112-folded
the number being benefited
by advanced technology.
But all this was a
very slow feedback
from the preoccupation
with how to kill.
So I said, supposing we
didn't wait for that,
but looked at the
home front right away.
I was indicated by this
three tons against 150
that maybe we could really get
doing so much with so little,
we could really demonstrate
to humanity there really
is enough to go around.
So that was 52 years ago, and I
have engaged in that direction
ever since.
Then and now that
brought me across into
geodesic structures,
where I could do very much
more with very much less.
There are now over
200,000 of them
somewhere around the world.
They're in remote places
where the very highest kind
of performance is required,
where other kinds of structures
just would not do, whether
they're ringing in the DEW line
with radios or the experimental
station over the South Pole,
or whether radar on
top of Mount Fuji able
to withstand the most
extraordinary hurricanes
and gales, snow loads.
So delicate that microwaves
can go through, yet so light
that one helicopter
took it up there
and fastened it in place
like a great bird landing.
So I've had enough
experience in the logistics
of environment controlling.
And due to the factor also,
I've been counting on,
since 1927, what I
call the World Game.
Instead of the navy
game of World War games
where the people in the
land were not concerned,
but the Navy was concerned
because 3/4 of this is water.
And then who's going to get
control of the line of supply?
That's the whole the story.
And how many resources are
there around the world?
Whole training of the navy
was to learn those things.
And now I said, I'm going to
play a game called World Game
not World War Game, where
I look at the sum total
and see how I can use it, if
possible, to make all humanity
a success.
It seemed to be indicated
as implicit in this trending
of doing more with less.
Now, so I've kept
all kinds of curves.
I kept the curves of
the rate of increase
of the tensile
strengths in the steals,
and then got into the aluminum.
I found that I could predict the
aluminum curve would follow it.
And it did, et
cetera, et cetera.
And by keeping enough track
of all the total data,
I've been able then to be able
to say certain things back.
10 years ago, I was
able then, by actually,
design, able to say it
is now incontrovertibly
evidencable in engineering
that we within 10 years
have a design revolution where
using only proven technology,
using only metals already
mined that are recirculating,
it's perfectly feasible
within 10 years
to have all humanity
living at a higher
standard of living than any
humans have ever known before--
on a sustainable basis.
Because during
that same 10 years,
we can phase out forever all
further use of fossil fuels
and atomic energy.
We can live entirely
on our energy income.
Now, this became, as I say,
incontrovertibly demonstrable.
For instance, just
take the energy side.
We have a book which is
published by our World Game,
Energy, Earth, and Everyone.
You'll be able to get copies
of it from Doubleday in July.
The first printings
were exhausted,
and the title went from
the Straight Arrow Press
in San Francisco to
Simon and Schuster,
who sold it to Doubleday.
And Doubleday has been very
slow on bringing it out,
but it will be out in July.
You'll find absolute
incontrovertible ability
to live on our energy income.
And incidentally, I'd just like
to mention the following to you
as a world of technology.
In World War II, the grand
strategy against Hitler
was then to cut off his energy.
And they were able to then
bomb Ploesti and so forth
immediately.
The German scientists
went to work,
and they learned how to
keep their economy going
on their energy income
entirely from the vegetation.
They were able then, to, go
into the four kinds of alcohol
to Grand Central
Station of energy.
And from there, they could get--
you may have
remembered they also
developed the very high
performance rubber, where
instead of having the 10,000
mile tires, got up to 50,000.
And they did this
all on alcohol.
All coming entirely
from vegetation,
they were able then to produce
high octane gas, gasoline.
They were able to produce food.
And they kept their
economy going.
It's very amazing to me that
the United States rushing in
as they did in Berlin--
and because I was in the
broader economic world,
and I know we had all that data.
None of this data
had been brought out
and the energy mentioned to you.
I want you realize that
there's-- why didn't that come
out?
Well, the next thing
I've discovered,
having made a statement such
as I have just made to you,
I'd been able to
make it 10 years ago
and have been making
it publicly ever since.
You get checked up
at such statements.
And possibly over a thousand
really quite confident people
have checked over my
data found it's correct.
It may be about a million people
who have credited those 1,000.
But there are 4
billion human beings,
so humanity doesn't know this.
But there is an
increasing number
who know that it's possible.
Now, the next thing I discovered
was that all big government--
which is political--
all big politics, all big
religion, all big business
found it absolutely
devastating an activity
to have humanity a success.
They're all predicated on
humanity being in trouble.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
FULLER: Come to me.
Join our side.
We can get you a
little better deals.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: You're poor people.
Come here.
I'll comfort you and get
you into Heaven, you know?
All the different things.
Everything predicated on man
being in great pain, trouble.
So then I realized that
rather big individuals who
might be very excited
by anything you
as the little
individual might do
in way of finding a better
way of sun energy impounding--
because it all
comes from the sun.
They pay lip service to
you, but big government's
going to do nothing about it.
So I mean to say, what
are our odds here?
Here we come to new knowledge,
first time in history,
we don't have to be a failure.
If we don't have
to be a failure,
it doesn't have to be
you or me ever again.
It doesn't have to be any war.
You don't have to
rationalize selfishness.
rationalize why
your family is a
little more deserving
than the other fellow's family.
It's why you should
cheat the other guy.
Just think if we get in
that kind of relationship
to the universe.
Anyway, I said that does not
seem to me to be unreasonable.
But it does follow that
hydrogen atom doesn't
have to earn a
living when it's not
behaving like a hydrogen atom.
In fact, the only
function that's
come in the universe, that had
to do this you or me-ing, as
far as I know, is human beings.
There's all the
rest of the universe
working very extraordinarily,
eternally regenerative.
The only 100% efficient
system we know of.
Now, this then brought
me to observing
everything else I could,
and evolution is going on.
I'll give a very big
evolutionary event.
Historically, humans, like other
mammals, the female carrying
the young, can't cover
as much geography
annually as can the male.
The North American wolf averages
a very much greater sweep out--
the male does than the female.
And so we have these in humans.
The human female then
learned to get a fire going,
and she could then keep the
food lasting a little longer.
She learned how to dry it.
She stayed around the hearth
preserving and consolidating
the gains.
The man was a hunter,
and he'd bring
in a new kind of creature.
She would decide whether
to skin it or milk it.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: And so gradually, the
man not only was the hunter,
but he also was a newsbringer.
Because he got to the top of
the mountain, and other people
hadn't been there.
So to all the children
through history, mom and dad
were the authority on
what you can to eat--
what their was that dad and mom
and found that you could eat,
what the chieftain would
put up with, and so forth.
Dad and mom were the authority
for this new little life here.
Not only that, but dad in
addition was the newsman.
And dad's language is very
inadequate and very poor
over the great ages, but anyway.
What he'd seen from the
top of the mountain,
or he'd heard that
the chieftain said--
and his language was very poor.
But the kids, then--
dad is the authority,
and this is the way dad says it.
So the esoteric way of
communication went to the kids
all right, but it started
more and more dialects
and different languages.
Suddenly, we have--
I said the electron
coming in when I'm three.
The year I was 23, we had
the human voice on the radio.
The year I was 27, we had the
first licensed broadcasting
radio station.
In 1927, all the daddies
were coming home one evening,
and all the kids said,
Daddy come in and listen
to the radio.
A man's flying
across the Atlantic.
And Daddy never brought
the news home ever again.
It stopped.
Nobody thought about
this anthropologically.
The news was it, and you're
preoccupied with the news.
But the fact was,
then, the people
who got the job on
the radio got it
by virtue of the
commonality of their diction
rather than special esoteric
way that Daddy said it.
And they updated by virtue
of the size of vocabulary
and they were skilled
in employing it.
That's where they got their
jobs and then maintained them.
And there's liquidity in
which they could get it out.
So the kids then saw dad and
mom listening to that radio.
And they saw dad run
across the street telling
what the radio man said.
So quite clearly, dad and
mom were the authority,
but these were
more of authority,
because dad and mom
are learning from them.
So the kids then emulated
the words the way
the great authority said it.
This completely changed the
speech pattern of humanity.
One of the things I've lived
through was that change.
I'll show you.
Here in Boston, my first
job before World War I,
I worked with some
very expert craftsman,
very fine human beings.
They're very lovable.
But their vocabulary
was about 100 words,
50% blasphemous and obscene.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: Mainly the way
they spit to let you
know how they feel about it.
But this has really changed.
It's incredible to me.
I now have been around
the world 44 times,
and the vocabulary around the
world is just extraordinary.
I can really use the
very best I have in me,
and I find myself being
understood very readily.
Now, this all changed
in our lifetime,
and it came about by
virtue of that radio
and getting some commonality
of diction at some point.
Now, the next thing that happens
is, nobody said to the kids,
this is a great authority.
It simply is self-evident that
this is the great authority.
Now, the kids instinctively
follow the great authority.
The child wants to know.
So then, as you know,
the speed of sound
approximately 700 miles an hour.
The speed of light,
approximately 700 million miles
an hour.
Approximately a
million times faster.
And sound only operates
in our atmosphere,
and the light goes right on.
The amount of information
you get visually
in ratio to what you get through
your ears is a million-fold.
So suddenly we have the
young students at Berkeley
out in California making
the world news as dissenters
about the educational system.
That particular group asked
me to come and meet with them,
and I met their contemporaries
at many universes out here.
They graduated, and the majority
of them graduated in '66.
Suddenly, I found
those kids were
born the year the television
came in the American home.
And they all said, I know that
dad and mom love me to pieces.
I love dad and mom to pieces.
But they don't know
what's going on,
have the slightest
idea what was going on.
They don't have anything to
do with our going to Korea
or going to the moon.
They don't have to
do with anything.
They're just lovable
human beings,
but the world is in trouble.
And this information we're
getting from around the world
now, not just locally anymore.
Well, I guess, I had very local
information when I was young.
They're really
getting world news.
The world's in trouble.
The older people don't
know what's going on.
I've got to do my own thinking.
Now, I'll show you
one of the things that
was very different about this.
When I was young--
my father died when
I was very young.
And my mother said, I'm
going to send you to the best
school I can afford to do.
I don't have very much money.
We're going to want you--
and she said, darling,
never mind what you think.
Listen.
We're trying to teach you.
I went to school, and they
said, never mind what you think.
This is what we're
trying to teach you.
We're intended to only no
never mind what you think.
I was also being told
by men as I got older
that life was very tough.
It had to be you
or me, so you've
got to get over all
your sensitivity.
Get over your sensitivity and
never mind what you think.
So I found myself out
of the gate with it
all So it was sort of a
game that you had to learn.
And so I learned the
game as best I could.
But nobody's saying
to the young world
anymore, never mind
what you think.
There's just none of it.
We suddenly have a young world--
that's just going back
then to the '60s--
where suddenly a young world
started doing his own thinking.
He's very knew at
that, very idealistic.
With Russia and the United
States spending $200 million
a year on how to destroy.
They appropriate about $20
billion a year or 10% of it
on how to break down
the other man's economy
before you get to the war.
And that's it.
So the United States
had free press
that was very much
easier to operate
against than the
Russian side where
they didn't have free press.
I heard the Russians say-- they
said to me many times, I can't
understand why you
keep a free press,
because we can get a
bonfire going in America,
it goes all over the place.
At any rate, we
have then there was
no question about
the young people who
were very idealistic being
exploited very ingeniously.
And so there were all kinds
of activism then in the '60s.
But then suddenly the kids found
they were using their heads
for battering rams.
They said, I should use
my head for thinking, not
for a battering ram.
And so they began to
develop an immunization
to the being exploitable.
So today, they're
nowhere nearly.
Each year, I'm finding
a very great difference.
I have been a visitor
now at 550 university
college around the world.
Many of the colleges
many times--
like MIT, in almost
innumerable times.
I really have quite a
good feeling for you
to tell you that there
is a very great strength
in that young world today
doing its own thinking,
and realizing it isn't
an invisible world.
And you're going
to have then have
competence to carry on
in the invisible world,
the invisible reality.
Which is what you have
here at MIT of all places.
So the next thing I saw was each
child being born successively
was being born in the presence
of less misinformation.
And each new child
being born successfully
being born in the presence of
much more reliable information.
Now, I saw that--
I'm getting letters
today, not so frequently,
but I get them,
say, four or five
a year from 8- and
10-year-olds who've been
born after man got to the moon.
And how they find that I'm
someone they can write to,
I don't know, but they do.
Their letters are
beautifully written.
And they say, humanity can
do anything it needs to do.
Why don't we make
this thing work?
They're completely full
of concern about it.
And I say, nature is coming
through with something new
here in the way of capability.
And so I have you also being
born naked, helpless, ignorant,
having to learn by
trial and error.
Humanity then gained the point
where it did develop words,
did gain a whole
lot of information,
but made an incredible number
of misinterpretation about--
[AUDIO OUT]
--you take a polished steel
ball 16 inches in diameter,
it would probably be rougher
than our Earth's planet.
Pictures taken of our planet
coming in from outer space,
we can see through
the cloud cover.
You can see the blue
water, the brown land,
but you can't see mountains
let alone human beings.
You and I standing on top of one
another's head making a chain,
it'd take 10,000 of us
to make a difference
between the outermost and
innermost points of our Earth.
So you and I are
1/10,000 invisible.
Now, our planet Earth's diameter
is about 1/100 that of the sun.
If you look at the
sun in the afternoon
when there's cloud in front
of his white does disc,
take coins out of your pocket
at arm's length to try to cover
it.
A nickel just about covers it.
You'll find that the size
of our Earth against that--
our school rulers
remember, 1/16 of an inch.
What, engineering scales get
down 1/50, 1/100 of an inch.
But beyond there,
everything gets blurred.
You have the very
finest printing
where seeing absolute continuity
of red and the colors,
you have 1/200 of an inch.
Anyway, our planet Earth
is so small against the sun
as you and I couldn't see
it, you couldn't see it.
So you and I are
invisible on our planet,
and our planet's invisible
against the sun, which
is rather an inferior star.
We have 100 billion
stars in our galaxy.
And let's look at Orion's
belt at two bright stars.
One one of them,
Betelgeuse, its diameter
is greater than the orbit
of the Earth around the sun.
So there's a good
sized star, all right.
But understand we have
a very small size where
there are 100 billion
stars in our galaxy.
We now know of 2
billion such galaxies.
Obviously, that kind
of universe is not
interested in whether the
Republicans or Democrats are
being elected.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
FULLER: Nor is it interested in
our baseball news or anything
else.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
FULLER: We on our
planet here, Earth,
are talking practically insanity
in relation to our universe.
So I saw that nature,
then, did this cut off
where she had all of
us in this group womb,
and with all the resources
by trial and error
to get enough information
to get a point where we make
some completely new judgments--
the kind of information
I, luckily, happened to be just
functioning-- did come to it.
We now know there's
enough to go around.
It's clearly demonstrable.
At which point we
really have to have
a completely new generation.
So I see when nature
has a child in the womb,
then the child has
to have oxygen.
But the mother is out
where the oxygen is,
and so she does the
breathing, gets it
in the bloodstream
and the umbilical cord
to get to the child.
When the child comes out
it, you cut the umbilical
because it's now got its own.
I think nature, then had what
I call a metaphysical cord.
She had where the older people
telling the younger ones what
they've been able to
find out to accumulate
and to get some words,
to get a working start.
But we got to the
point where there
are so many misinterpretations
of the significance
have been made that the
time came for a cut off.
So she suddenly has this
young world cut-off.
I said, I don't want to do that.
To me, it's an enormous,
enormous evolutionary event,
incredibly big
evolutionary event,
that a young world is
suddenly doing the thinking.
As I said, I brought
up here-- never.
All the older world assuming
the thinking capabilities
of the young are
absolutely unreliable.
So here we are in
this new chapter.
And I can see that maybe that
new young that's coming through
will really take over.
And things are becoming
less and less tenable.
Now we've found quite
a long time ago--
the great religions
realized they could not
stay operating just
within 150 pens--
nations-- so they
became transnational.
And we found all big
business found that.
They've all gone transnation,
taking all the money out
of America, incidentally.
So the Americans
have 4 billion people
in 150 pens subject to drafting,
and any of the big powers
can use it, just throw
you up against their enemy
whether you like it or not.
But we're under a
condition now where,
fortunately, we've discovered
this scrap recirculation.
We don't have to do any mining.
And that's scrap recirculation.
We have 150 pens.
We really have 150 blood clots.
For the economics to really
work for the recirculating,
regenerative universe, which
we're finding ourselves in.
Suddenly, yesterday
looking out just this way,
we now discover
ecology over here,
that the whole system
is regenerative.
So we're part of an enormous
regenerative system--
the universe itself.
But things are going off
like that rather than
in front of us.
I just feel that there's
a great, great possibility
that this younger world will
very quickly reject something.
I'm going to run some
slides for you now because I
want to get a little
sense of acceleration
and some other big
evolutionary events.
May I have side number one?
This slide number one.
Does anybody know
what that picture is?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: I took it from a high
school wall in New York City.
On it, Greenland is
bigger than South America.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: North--
America we're very big.
We're bigger than Africa.
The United States is
enormous, much bigger
than Europe and everything else.
So it's very flattering.
But this part of
Russia over here
seems to be 25,000 miles, that
far, Russia only a mile apart.
So there's no Antarctica.
That we could show
this to kids at school
to come and keep selling
such junk as this,
that seems to be
incredible to me.
I said years ago, I
want to really think
about total inventory
of our resources.
I need a background
against which
there's no visible distortion.
I'd like to be able to
take the data of a sphere
and project it out on the flat.
And I discover a
way of doing it.
I'd like to tell you rather
quickly how it is completely
unlike any of the
methods of projections
that have been used.
As we find mathematically,
you can divide--
you can get three
triangles around a corner
in a spherical tetrahedron.
You can get four
equilateral triangles
around an octohedron's corner.
You can get five
icosahedron around a corner.
You can't get six
because you have 60, 60,
and you have 360 degrees.
It'd be a plane
going to infinity,
so in order to come
back in the south,
the limited number of
equilateral triangles
around a corner
can only be five.
I took this
spherical icosahedron
with its 20 equilateral
triangles-- each of the corners
are 72 degrees.
And I found a method then.
If you think about
a steel band--
three steel bands that
have inch marks on them,
if I bend one of
them, the inch marks
remain still an inch apart.
If I then take three
such bands, and I
am going to take each
of those bands and weld.
Each one would be 12
inches long, the band.
And I've got a
12-inch long rod going
through each one at its point,
perpendicularly through it,
welding it into place--
a very stiff carbon rod.
And so it's 6 inches
above, 6 inches below.
If I take those
ends of those rods
and pull them together
with one steel band,
the whole band will just bend.
But the 1 inch points on
the band don't change.
They hold a uniform
scale whether flat
or in the band condition.
If I take three
such steel rulers
with three sets of
rods going through them
as I spoke about it, and I
put a little bolt at the ends
to make it into triangles, it
looks like a triangular fence.
Now I'm going to take all
the bottom of all those rods
and pull them together.
It makes each of the bands bend,
but it makes two of the bands
bend away from the third band.
It opens up the
angle of the corner,
makes sure it goes
spherical triangle.
So it gets up to 72 degrees
and has to be, then, spherical.
So with the icosahedron, I
have 20 spherical triangles.
Each of those corners
is 72 degrees.
When I take them off, holding
my uniform boundary scale
so we don't let any infinity
in the system at all,
then the corner angles
go from 72 to 60,
which is called 12
degrees spherical excess.
But because it's done absolute
symmetrically in equal angle
triangles, then there's
shrinkage of the data
inside the triangle
but not along the edge.
The edge old absolutely true.
There's a very mild
shrinkage internally,
and it's mostly the center.
And the shrinkage
is so minor, there's
no visual distortion
between the relative shape
and size of any of the parts
on the sphere or on the flaps.
Now, I'm going to show
you a map which will not
look familiar to you at all.
Next picture, please.
This is made out
of my triangles,
which are such that--
I wonder if I could get somebody
to help me a little more.
Claude?
I think that there is a
light pointer, is there not?
[INAUDIBLE]?
Good.
I think I can get
up here quite well.
There are on this map,
incidentally, 100 white dots.
Each one is 1% of humanity
located very accurately
for the center of
that many people.
On this picture, let's look at--
here is, then, Greenland.
There's Greenland.
And you can see then it's
1/3 the size of Australia.
And now we have the
Antarctic showing.
Now, I gave you, then, the
dots are the human beings--
1% each.
And here's the Equator
going through South America.
Only three dots south of it.
Here's where the Equator
goes through Africa.
You have only two
dots south of it.
I have it going where it
goes, through Java, Sumatra.
Sum totally, 10 white dots
are south of the Equator,
but get very close
to the Equator.
90% of humanity lives
north of the Equator,
and the small 10% that's
a little below it.
Thank you, sir, very much.
Now here, there's where the
Equator goes through Africa.
Here's where the Equator's
going through here.
And s Java and Sumatra here.
Mainly, then we the people
living in the southern half,
and humanity knows
very, very little
of this great
southern hemisphere.
We just came to the Antarctic
when I was 16 years of age.
We have then--
I spoke to you
about the British.
This is a water ocean world.
And this is the way things were
when I was young, and it took--
all those people who
wrote to one another,
it took them six months
to reach each other.
My father was in
the-- here we are
in Boston in the leather
importing for the great shoe
business here.
He imported from Buenos
Aires and Calcutta.
It took him exactly two months
to go to South America each
way-- two months each way--
and it took him exactly three
months to get to Calcutta--
and three months each way.
So humanity was really divided.
This is what typically
he called the East,
and this is what
he called the West.
And he said east is
east, and west is west.
Never the twain shall
meet because he did not
live in an airplane world.
He was thinking
in a water world.
And here we have then that 54%
of humanity, 29%, and here,
the Americas is
only 12% altogether.
Now, in that water
world, you could not
change your cargoes at sea.
The two ships would
chew each other up.
So harbors were of the
greatest importance
for that great
international trade.
And so that's coming
to America-- to Boston.
We had St. Lawrence, which
would freeze up in the winter.
Boston Harbor many times
got pretty badly iced up.
And there's nothing to
compare with New York
Harbor with deep water
and an enormous amount
of deep waterfront,
well-protected inside
of the Long Island
and Staten Island.
Then we have-- on
the West Coast,
we had San Francisco, Seattle.
There are relatively few
good harbors in the world.
And North America,
then, would be
able to build a railroad
between the East and West
of the San Francisco and
the New York, and so forth.
Now in 1961, three jet
airplanes which nobody knew
were going to be coming,
three jet transport airplanes
outperformed the Queen Mary,
Queen Elizabeth-- the steamship
of the United States.
In the year 1961, ships of
the sea became obsolete.
Again, a big, big evolutionary
event for how humanity
goes from here to there.
From here on,
we're getting there
by air, which was utterly
undreamed of in my mother's
time.
So we have, then--
here's that great
water ocean world.
And the British,
who were running it,
then found if you got down
to the Southern Pacific here,
you'd get on the
roaring force of how the
what goes around west to east.
The water went faster than
the crystalline Earth,
and the winds even faster still.
So we had what I call a Roaring
Forties going around here.
There's no such
thing in the Arctic.
But in the Antarctic, there is.
And you can see where the great
ice floes chewed through what
we call the Great Horn.
So the British discovered
all you had to do
was come south in the Pacific,
get in the Roaring Forties,
you're going right
to the Atlantic.
Come the south Atlantic,
ride on the Roaring Forties--
in the Indian Ocean.
Indian Ocean-- right
in the Pacific again.
What do the British got?
They got the southern tip of
South America, Africa, South
Africa, Australia, New Zealand.
They got on the merry-go-round.
The people all the
way out here, no idea.
So this is a picture
you're seeing first time
the British Empire,
which they were not
eager for anybody to see.
Anywhere, there it is.
And now 1961, those
airplanes they arrived sad.
Next picture, please.
Number two.
So suddenly we have here what
I called a sky-ocean world.
It's the first time
in your life or any--
if you haven't seen
this map before,
it's the first time
humanity is able to see
all of the surface of our Earth
without any visible distortion
of the relative shape or
size of any of the parts
and without any break in
the continental contours.
We have one world island
and one world ocean.
It took me two years
to find out how to get
all those sinuses in the water.
But at any rate, there it is.
So suddenly this is the
new intimacy-- this way.
This is the way we're
going to be going.
And we're still--
I was just reading
this day's paper
about New York getting
in a new convention
center for $350 million.
There's so much property in
New York and San Francisco
that they'd do anything to
have conventions somehow,
to keep it going.
But absolutely dead--
obsolete, utterly obsolete.
We have then, when I was
young, 90% of Americans
were on farms-- today, only 7%.
And all the people that started
for a moment hanging fire
are using those cities.
There are dormitories, the
sort of big university areas,
but they're obsolete as
anything to do with the way they
were conceived originally.
And now on this map,
you'll find humanity.
And I find that it is--
95% of humanity can reach
each other on the shortest
great circle air routes without
going near the Atlantic,
Pacific, or Indian Ocean.
So this is a north-south world.
And I found something
else very fascinating.
It's coming in with the--
you may remember that the
delivery of electricity,
delivery of energy
from here there,
there's no way we get so
much so fast as by wire.
And the limit of the practical
deliverability from World War I
on up to recently was
only 350 miles when
you go across the time zones.
But since the space
program came in
and got what it called
ultra high voltage,
we have Americans now
deliver 1,500 miles.
I made a world network of
electrical energy networks
not only then showing how we
then go across our time zones.
And anyway, those times
zones would reach very nicely
from here to Alaska.
And in Alaska, we can
reach right across.
The Russians have been building
hydraulic electric stations
along all their
northern-flowing rivers in here.
1,500 miles, you can reach
across to the Russian network.
And that means you can get
into the China network and all
the rest of the world.
Now, when Trudeau was about to
make his first trip to Russia--
we are friends, and I showed
him my electrical energy network
grid.
And he was very excited by it.
So he took it.
He gave it to Breshinev,
and Breshinev had
his technical people check in.
They said it looked very,
very practical to them.
I can simply say to you with
all the nonsense going on
in our world--
money world today--
we've completely
separated money from wealth.
Wealth being the ability
to take care of human life.
We have, as I just gave
you a little while ago,
the ability to take
care of everybody
at the highest
standard as others.
We have 4 billion
billionaires on the planet
right now, by the way.
The game of money being played
keeps everything very scarce
again.
So the money game is going
to go out completely.
We're going to be a mess.
And what will happen is
we'll all get onto the--
what it the accounting
system of the universe?
It's energy.
And energy and time.
Energy and time--
and nothing else.
And so we're going to
get on energy time.
So the minute we get
on the same grid,
it's going to be very, very easy
to really have the vaccinating
or whatever we need to do.
Way of accounting can be
done this way absolutely
beautifully.
So I want to give you a
few little quick insights.
Now, that is all I'm
going to show you
in the way of pictures.
All I wanted to do was--
may we have the lights on?
I mainly just wanted to give you
a sense of very swift-- oh, no.
One-- whoa, whoa stop.
One more, one more,
one more, one more.
All right.
Sharpen it up best you can.
Now, people you won't to
be able to read this chart,
so I'll just simply tell
you what it's all about.
It is a chart that
is 800 years long.
And-- am I in your
way too much here?
This chart-- I wanted
to have, as I call it,
a way of charting gains
of science against time.
Within science, of course,
we have then, as you say,
pure science.
And then within pure science,
we have the isolating
of the chemical elements.
And the isolating
the chemical elements
happens to be a
closed system affair
where membership is absolute
and right by the number.
And that's all the
numbers have to be filled.
We have one electron, one
photon, et cetera, et cetera.
Nobody can cheat, at any rate.
We have, when history opens,
humanity had already discovered
and was using the--
we have carbon lead, tin,
mercury, silver, copper,
sulfur, gold, and iron.
On this chart, I go up
one step every time we've
isolated a chemical element.
So it starts nine steps high.
It's 1200 AD is the first known
isolation of a chemical element
by a human being--
arsenic.
That's where my chart starts.
We go 200 years, then
we come to antimony.
200 years more, then phosphorus.
Then 75 years, and it suddenly
starts climbing very rapidly.
You see an accelerating
time and a slow down time--
accelerating, a slow down.
The accelerations
are always peacetime.
These slowdowns
are always wartime.
Now, we get to a point where--
and I'll get the pointer again.
And suddenly this very much
was flattening out here.
This is 1932, so the
depth of the Depression,
but also the year
in which we made
the 91st isolation of chemical
element only 90 out of 92--
91 only present on the
planet, so we could isolate.
Any rate, we have
here the, the shelves
have fallen for the
first time in history.
We've taken the
physical universe
apart into its own
unique chemical elements
to be reassociated
into preferable ways.
From there on, we get
into post-uranium,
and then suddenly
it's going like this.
Now, very interesting,
they come in here.
They don't come in by the
number of chemical number.
37 might be the seventeenth
isolation, and so forth.
But from here on,
they're coming in exactly
by the numbers, which is a
very extraordinary thing.
Any rate, against this
background of pure science,
we have, then, applied
science, obviously.
And what does humanity try to
do with this type of capability?
It tries to clothe--
it starts naked, yes?
And then it gets
some skins on it,
so it gets ready
to get in the cold.
Then you put a double
skin in a tent,
and get ready for colder still.
Against this
background of science,
I give humanity the requirement
to develop an environment
control device.
Which you can get into,
and from inside of it,
control the energies
operating outside
to take him in one complete
circuit of our planet.
But we're going to have an
absolutely standard performance
requirement against
his background.
Here he goes around
in a wooden sailing
ship for the first time.
350 years later, he goes
around in a steel steamship.
75 years later, goes around
in an aluminum airplane.
35 years later, he goes around
in an exotic metal rocket.
At the time when this
wooden sailing ship,
nobody could dream of the
possibility of a steel
steamship.
At the of the steel
steamship, nobody
could dream of an aluminum
airplane, let alone
we hadn't learned to fly yet.
Time of the airplane, nobody
could dream of an exotic metal
rocket.
So yes, having some enormous
acceleration going on here.
You have this basic acceleration
of science against time.
We have a contraction of 350
years, 75 years, 35 years.
This one took two
years to go around.
months to go around.
This took two
weeks to go around.
This one took a
little over one hour.
You're witnessing
quite visibly three--
third power acceleration.
It's implicit on this chart.
If we go to 1985,
right in here, I'm
going to have to send
you around in a way
inconceivable in the
time of the exotic--
I'm going to have to
send you around by radio.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: This chart is
the most powerful thing
I've ever had to get
me to really feel--
want you to feel-- the
acceleration that we're in.
Because all of the
things that you
have been very familiar with,
like the nations are going
to go, and you
see, in this case,
the United States going into
bankruptcy, going into--
all these great power really
going downhill very rapidly.
You're going to have all
kinds of things coming apart
that you've been
very familiar with.
And in its place,
you're going to be
coming at some of the things
I've been talking to you about.
I've taken lot of your time.
Let me see what we are at
in the way of the clock.
That is the end of slides.
You can put on the
lights again now.
It is now 9:30.
I've been exactly the hour and
a half that we're supposed to.
Now we're supposed to
get into questions.
You have a choice of asking
me questions or letting
me ask myself the questions
I've been asking myself
for a very long time
and answering them
in some kind of order for you.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
FULLER: I have a
telephone, and I
keep getting telephone calls at
3 and 4 o'clock in the morning.
And people say, I'm
calling you long distance,
and that seemed to
justify the strange hour.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: I say, do I know you?
And they say, no.
And I say, I've got a very
important question to ask you.
I said, all right.
I assume then you must
think I have an answer.
That's why you're calling.
I do have an answer because 52
years ago, I made up my mind.
I'm not going to ask
anybody else any question.
I'm going to find
out for myself.
So if you really want me to
help you, I suggest you hang up.
And I listen.
I listen, and granted, I say,
a few of them do hang up.
But they start their
talking, and then I
know they're just lonely,
call up to show off.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: So I hang up.
[APPLAUSE]
FULLER: Anyway, I
would like to give you
a little bit of what I think
of some of the things that--
you're going to not only see
all the great nations going
and going.
They'll have to
go with 10 years.
I feel that to--
to have a very--
I'm going to carry
through a little more
on the function of humans in
universe, which I spoke about
as having a mind capability.
I said, what can I find
that's common to all lives
in all history right up
to this minute, second?
That is, common to all lives
are problem, problems, problems.
That all of us here are
for problem solving.
And if we're any good
at problem solving,
you get much more difficult
problems to solve.
It don't come to utopia at all.
It was exactly the
opposite direction.
That we're quite here
for problem solving,
and we've been
given access to some
of the great design of universe
to help us solve the problems.
I say, let's you and I look at a
great design like a Boeing 747,
go up inside of all
these instruments.
And all those
instruments are connected
with different
parts of your ship,
and the power plant,
and the airframe.
Every bit of critical
information regarding that ship
is coming to you.
And this is inherently
just to people
who don't get into technology
to think about what's
really going on here.
In designing a single
family residence,
500 drawings is the
most you have to have.
You may use 1,000 of this
type of nail, but 500 will do.
And the tolerance--
1/16 of an inch is fine.
Get into the automobile
which is moving around
in different parts
at different rates.
We have to really
look out for that.
We get to 5,000 types of parts
in an automobile and tolerances
of 1/10,000 of an inch.
We're getting that Boeing 747,
we're up to about 50,000 types
of parts with tolerances
sometimes 1/1,000,000
of an inch.
There's more engineering goes
in one rivet in a Boeing 747
than a whole single
family dwelling or even
the automobile.
And then that beautiful
thing in the sky,
it has to be able to
take 650 miles an hour,
which is 10 times the
velocity of a hurricane.
And the resistance increases
second power of the speed
so that the ferocity of the
interaction of the Boeing
747 with atmosphere is 100 times
the ferocity of a hurricane.
There's no way for our
imagination to really--
and there's that thing going
around the silver thing going
like that.
You take 350 tons and land
it at 150 miles an hour.
The music going is
quite a piece of design.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: When they say, better
fasten your seat belts,
it's bumpy today, the stress
involved with that ship is
the equivalent to taking
Queen Mary over Niagara Falls
and saying its' bumpy today.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: It's an incredible
piece of design.
And humanity knows
so little of this.
The ignorance of
humanity because of what
I've said of the invisibility
of the reality is, as I said--
today, there are 40 million
engineers and scientists
on our planet, but that's
only 1% of humanity.
And the 99% don't
understand science
because they don't understand
the language of science.
And the 99% who don't understand
the language of science,
and words being
quite new to them,
think of the word
technology as something new.
They don't know that all
the science we've ever found
is the universe's most
incredible technology.
So the 99% think of
technology as something new--
as weaponry and machinery
to compete for their jobs.
And they think
they're against it.
So here we have humanity
as only out to really make
it is by a design revolution,
using technology to really make
humanity a success, to be
proud of the great success
of the universe itself.
So that's really
a very tough one.
And that relates primarily to
the fact that the mathematics
is a blockage--
where it's indigestible
to leave many.
I'd like to get that point
out of the way in a hurry.
I became convinced when I
was very young the nature was
coordinating in a way that
was not best expressed
by the mathematics
I was being taught.
I've been taught, for
instance, about pi--
that you couldn't design
a circle or sphere
without using pi.
And I was taught, as I
stayed in mathematics,
that pi was what is called
transcendental irrational.
It could never be resolved.
So I said, every time
nature makes a bubble,
how many times does
she carry out pi
before she discovers
it can't be resolved?
What time does nature decide
to make a fake bubble?
I don't think
nature is using pi.
I don't think nature has
a departments of physics,
and mathematics,
and biology, and has
to have department head
meeting to know what to do
when a leaf falls in the water.
She has only one department, and
I'm eager to find it if I can.
And I found nature never
saying, what shall I do?
I don't have to make--
nature knew I wouldn't
know what to do.
And nature knew
exactly what to do.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: So I said,
I'd like to find
nature's coordinate system.
And I don't think it's
going to be x, y, z,
flat, perpendicular. world
because that was when
we thought of the flat Earth.
So that would have been very
convenient if it was true.
And I said, I made myself a
tubular necklace of four tubes,
and I found it didn't
hold its shape.
So I don't think she's
using a square either,
because it there's no such
thing that won't hold its shape.
I think nature-- if I want to
get anywhere near what she's
doing, I'm going to
have to deal in her
in the terms of right from the
beginning with all the energy
qualities.
It has to have heat.
It has to have longevity.
It has to have weight.
And I saw the centimeter,
grams, seconds systems
tried very hard to get it.
But they never could
get the temperature in.
So I said, well, I'm
going to deal in vectors.
I like vectors, and
I learned about those
at the Naval Academy.
I'd been taught about a straight
line by my teacher at school.
She said, there's
a straight line.
I said it didn't look
very straight to me.
But she said it was.
And she said it
went to infinity.
And I said, where's
the other gone?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: And she
couldn't tell me.
So I didn't like the kinds of
things being taught at school
at all.
And I finally then
got into pursuing
nature's own coordinates.
And I'll point out to you
that nature does not operate
perpendicularly parallel.
Nature is convergent
And divergent.
She is radiation, divergent,
gravitation, convergent--
everything that
experience says has
to do with waves going
omnidirectionally.
So I've discovered nature's
own coordinate system.
It turns out to be a
nominally triangulating world
where the minimum smallest
system in universe
is a tetrahedron.
The minimum-- the only polygon
that is self-stabilizing
is a triangle.
And that is-- the tetrahedron
is the smallest, simplest
structural system in
the universe so far.
We've gone into this.
And you can read my book,
Synergetics, at any rate.
And another book-- volume
two-- will be coming out
in September of this year.
And it's very much
more voluminous.
And we're absolutely
confident now we really
have found nature's coordinate
system-- entirely rational.
It's entirely conceptual,
and any little child
could really understand it.
And enough about that.
But I think it's going
to be possible, then,
through the video so the
great 99% of humanity
who don't understand
science and technology
can become extremely
appreciative of it
really almost overnight.
And that will make
it possible, then,
to get them oriented towards
exercising the option to make
it with a design revolution.
Now coming back to
humans in universe
and their functioning,
and then the fact
that they have access to
great design of universe--
or some of it.
And they have then also
problems, problems, problems.
Coming back to that
great big Boeing 747--
superbly designed, all
those instruments up there,
giving me all the critical
conditions on board
the ship, both the power
plant and the airframe--
I'd say then next to each
one of those instruments
is liable to be another
dial which would be bringing
on automated response to the
typical set of conditions
that I'm obtaining.
And if those didn't work,
then the pilot himself
and the engineers could
take over on the controls.
At any rate, I'd say in order to
have an eternally regenerative
universe--
which is what we call a
scenario universe and not
an instant universe--
in order to have a totally
regenerative universe which
is 100% efficient, you'd have
to have some local information
gathering and some
local problem solving
in the terms of fundamentals of
design of that universe itself.
And I say, humans have
been given that capability.
Quite clearly, we've been
able to go out and get
that information 11 and 1/2
billion light years around us.
That we are here for local
information gathering,
local problem solving in
respect to maintaining
the integrity of an eternally
regenerative universe.
Now, nature then, when she
has an important function
to fulfill, does not
have, as they say,
all the eggs in one basket.
She-- for instance, in order
to have humans on the universe
to do this, we're
going to have to use
an enormous amount of energy.
We can't get enough through our
skin from the sun to carry on,
so we have all the
vegetation impounding
the sun radiation for us.
And then we have
that vegetation then
having to be rooted so
that it can get water,
it can withstand enormous
winds and also take
care of its hydraulic
pressure requirements
and get water back in the sky.
Because the
vegetation rooted, it
can't go out and plant its
seeds in preferred places.
So in nature, then, it
needs this very much
to keep the human being
going on our planet,
and she then has each tree
launching little flying
machines--
little seeds-- by the
many, many thousands.
A few of them may land where
they will be prospering.
Many of them will not.
So when she has a very important
function and very poor chance
of survival actually
being realized,
she makes many starts.
As I say, she would not have--
the function we have
to perform would not
be just in this one little
team on board our little planet
Earth.
The same function would
be planted many places
in the universe.
In this particularly
one, I say we've now
come through the being designed
deliberately naked, helpless,
ignorant.
We're getting to the
point where we discover
these beautiful principles,
that our minds are everything,
that muscle is nothing.
We're in final examination
now as to whether we're really
going to qualify.
And if we'd really qualify,
mind must take over,
and we must get out
of the way of ever
having to earn a living.
That really can't go on
with our real function
of solving local
problems of the universe
and getting more and
more information.
So I think I'll--
our examination from
my acceleration curve to say
we only have about 10 years
to make it.
In fact, I'm down to
about eight years now.
So it may be shorter still.
We don't know.
The acceleration is enormous.
That's the main thing.
And so then you say,
what can I do about it?
The way things are set up now,
all this political system,
and I don't have anything to do
with the political decisions.
Everything really depends
on you personally.
I wish I had a
blackboard here, but I'm
going to have to do
something with you mentally,
because we all have
very good imaginations.
I'm going to give
you a triangle.
And I'm going to bisect the edge
of that triangle in to connect.
I've The edge reads two--
edge module is two.
There's one, two,
three, four triangles.
Make a triangle, now the edge
module is going to be three.
One, two, three four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
Make an edge module of four.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16.
So 16 is two to
the second power,
and 9 is three to the
second power and so forth.
You could say triangling
instead of squaring.
And you find that only a
triangle is the only polygon
that holds its shape.
And you discover a
square is two triangles.
Nature is always
most economical.
When nature multiplies
herself down
to the cell, which she
does time and again,
which is nature doing?
Triangling or squaring?
I just gave you
experimental evidence.
Squares don't even
hold their shape.
Which is nature using?
If anybody goes out of
this room saying squaring,
humanity's all through.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: It's a question
from now on about
your personal integrity in
daring to really go along
with experimental evidence.
And really speak about it,
and do something about it.
If you do, then the whole
thing's going to work,
because we do have all
the evidence that we now
have the capability to make it.
So it's going to really depend
on your personal integrity.
I can give you the same
thing showing that--
I'll make a little cube
out of necklace of tubes.
It falls down.
I put triangles together,
it makes the octohedron.
Holds its shape.
All triangles do.
And when we use
a cube for unity,
as we do in centimeters, grams,
seconds, a cube of water,
et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera, we
find that the only reason
it holds the shape it does
is because you have six square
faces, don't you, on a cube?
If I put a diagonal
across each face,
it makes the six edges
of a tetrahedron.
There's a tetrahedron
holding it there.
And it has to do that
it has four, one, eight
octahedron superimposed
on the triangle
face of the tetrahedron.
When the tetrahedron is
unity, then the octohedron
has a volume of
four, and the cube
is exactly a volume of three.
And I could go on then to
show you that we can then--
with the tetrahedon and
octohedron filling space--
that we can call all
this the third power.
I can show you quite
clearly the module is one.
It comes out as one tetrahedron.
If the edge module is two,
it's eight tetrahedrons.
If the edge module is--
remember, tetrahedron
do not fill
all the space faced by himself.
They have to be completed by the
octohedron at a volume of four.
So I can simply show you that
the edge module reads three,
the volume is 27.
If the edge module
reads four, the volume
is 64 of the tetrahedron.
In terms of-- so I can say
tetrahedroning instead of
cubing.
And if I'm using
cubing, I'm using up
three times as much
universe is available.
And that's exactly why
the mathematics of science
is so absolutely ridiculous.
You had to get an imaginary
number and everything
to accommodate going
out of this universe.
Usually tetrahedrons say
right in the universe
is all conceptual, right
from beginning to end.
Don't have to have any nonsense
about there are no models.
When does nature suddenly
check in the models?
So we say it's
models all the way.
And all of it is completely
intertransformable.
But any rate, I go
into it in Synergetics.
So I say again, if
anybody goes out
of this room saying cubing when
you see third power, again,
we're all through, because
you need three times as much
universe as is available.
Fairly simple.
Now, so you--
I want to really get out what
I feel is what you personally
can do is going to be
really depending on
are you willing to really
have everybody accommodated?
Are you willing to have
everybody really get there?
Or are you got the
sort of ego that
doesn't want that to happen,
et cetera, et cetera?
Are you really going to go along
with the experimental evidence?
But whether we make
it or not, then,
is not a matter of how
our leaders behave.
It's how the humanity
itself behaves.
It's not a matter of
a few being surviving.
It's a matter of humanity.
And humanity's going to go by
virtue of fact you've all now
got a vocabulary.
You've all got an enormous
amount of information.
And then just how much
guts have you really
got to go along
with information?
The information is that all
the old systems are obsolete.
Not because they weren't
good yesterday at all.
They were absolutely essential,
like the umbilical cord
was essential at the time
it came out of the womb.
But we're coming out.
I'm not saying the flag
wasn't great yesterday
to what humanity's gone through.
Incredible courage, and love,
and dedication, humanity
gets where it is.
No faults at all with yesterday,
but we're out of that womb.
We're supposed to
be coming out now,
and birth is the most
dangerous time of all.
We're in birth.
So I am very deeply--
it's something I haven't said
anything about tonight at all.
In 1927, I made
up my mind to make
myself an experimental
experiment to see
how well the little individual
could really do and do
everything with artifacts, not
trying to reform human beings,
but by participating in
the environment itself.
Because I saw you
and I are 60% water,
and we're hydraulically
designed--
hydraulic compression,
et cetera.
That water freezes and boils,
and all the rest, so we'd
have to be in the biosphere.
And any other information
gaining phenomena operating
on Mars will not look the way
we do on this particular planet
here in the biosphere.
So I came to thinking
about many, many things--
certainly about life,
and integrity, and mind.
And I came to the
working conclusion--
I was just overwhelmed by the
a priori intellectual integrity
of our universe--
that there were those
generalized principles
to be discovered, and that they
really were a great design.
And that it could only be
intellectually expressed
mathematically.
So I said, I'm overwhelmed
with a great integrity.
And I'm assuming
then that I have
been born at a moment when
somebody's supposed to be
poking their neck through.
The information is here.
And I became really very
much an outsider because--
I just want you to
understand I did not
make good at the game of
making money and so forth.
I lost all of my friends' money.
I was not only
unknown generally,
but pretty much a disgrace
to the few who did know me.
And I said, I'm really
pretty much a throwaway.
And I'd like to see what
would happen if we really
made assumptions about all the
things that I'm giving to you.
That it was implicit
that we could do someday
so much with so little to
take care of everybody.
It was also, it
seemed to me, that I
saw that human beings
having this great hunger
and so forth, gradually learning
how to domesticate a milk cow,
then learn how to take the
hide of the cow and make shoes.
And the shoe man making more
shoes than he could wear.
And the shoe man
wants a milk cow,
and the milk cow man cow
wants a pair of shoes.
They realize they can't cut
the cow up and still milk it.
So then the man who
grew the milk cow,
it took him much more time
to grow the milk cow than it
took a man to make shoes.
So this is when they invented
money to make up for that.
So I saw that nature,
then, in order
to have human life going
on on our planet would
need a great deal of energy.
And I spoke about having to
have the vegetation to impound
the sun radiation for us.
And incidentally, to be
completely anti-entropic
as to take the random
seeds and convert them back
to beautiful, orderly,
molecular structures.
And which other
creatures could employ
to grow more and more
orderly types of species
so that the Earth was a
very anti-entropic affair.
At any rate, with the vegetation
then doing this impounding
and being rooted, it couldn't
reach the other vegetation
to procreate.
So nature then invented
all the mobile creatures,
whether worms or butterflies,
to go back and forth
between all the vegetation
to cross-pollinate them.
But nature didn't
say to the honey bee,
I want you to go out
and cross-pollinate
all this vegetation.
What nature did was give the
bee a chromosomic instruction
to go after honey.
It was continually after
honey, and inadvertently did
knock off the pollen.
So I saw nature was
accomplishing all these things
at 90 degrees.
You get drive like that.
So then she had all
the human beings--
honey money drive--
going after money.
And they've got a stinger.
And if anybody tried to take
my money, I'd sting them.
So I said, what she's really
doing is at 90 degrees.
So I said, supposing then I
make the working assumption
that what--
I've given them to you--
is that we have a function.
In fact, I've
committed myself to try
to abet that by developing
environment controls that
would help to make them able
to function more effectively.
It could be that if I was doing
what nature wanted, I'd get on.
It would be very mysterious.
So I made a working assumption.
It was enormous.
I said, I have to
have absolute faith
in the integrity of universe.
And that if I'm doing
what nature wants,
I'll find myself getting on.
That is 52 years ago, and I
have gone on all this time.
And I've had to say, only
the impossible has happened
continually, day after day.
And I have been able to get on.
I have been able to get the
artifacts out that I required.
Really, actually many millions
of dollars, actually-- but I
never know.
I have nothing to the
budget, really only up
to the absolute last second.
And then if I don't get one, I
realize I'm on the wrong track.
Because nobody backed
my paper but my own.
So I had to then say,
let's try this tack.
That wasn't the tack.
And what else, what
next needs to be done?
I've made an incredible
number of mistakes,
but I've been able to get here.
But I think it's worth your
while knowing that I do
represent also an experiment
in seeing if you can get on
if you really try to do what
nature wants to get done
rather than how do you
look after yourself.
Now, that the end.
I'm overwhelmed by
my faith in this way.
I tell you that like all human
beings, I couldn't be weaker.
I've made many mistakes.
At times, I lose my faith,
and everything goes wrong.
And every time it gets really
dead, if you yield absolutely,
then everything just
works out superbly.
Now-- so I say I know we
have the option to make it.
I think our time is very short.
I think if we're
going to make it,
it's going to be by the
virtue of youth and truth.
But really the most
extraordinary thing
about that young world, as all
worlds, is that feeling you had
of being loved.
And there's so many feeling
how we're suddenly loving.
So that young world knows
that stones don't love stones.
So there's something incredible
in the world of love.
So I find that young world,
nobody's saying to them,
get over your
sensitivity anymore.
They're really are
guarding their sensitivity.
So they have much more
integrity of daring
to really go along
with what they see
and what love tells them.
So say if we do make
it on a planet--
I know we have the
option-- it's going
to be by virtue of the fact
that the youth loves truth.
And the youth abhors hypocrisy.
So with the love of truth
of youth, we may make it.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
FULLER: I'd have been
very disappointed
if you didn't do that, and
I stood up hoping you would.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
FULLER: I'm-- for
the last five years,
I'm averaging an audience
of 1,500 every four days.
And if you didn't stand up,
you'd be the first audience
that didn't.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
FULLER: Now what I feel
is very important for you
is the following.
I spoke about 90 degrees
and said it like this.
It's a free session.
And if you're in the room
with me and like what I said,
you say, I liked what you said.
It reads pretty well
in my experience.
It seems very reasonable.
But when you're doing what
you just did, you're saying,
I'm going to tell
the people beside me
here that I like what you said.
So you're talking to
each other and not to me.
And that's very important.
Because if we get into very
critical issues ahead here,
we are very liable to have--
I want you to remember about
when Germany lost all its money
in World War I. They got into
a dictatorship, at which point
nobody is allowed to know
what the other one thinks.
You're told what to think.
And we're very
liable-- if we're going
to come in great
many emergencies,
there are liable to
be a lot of guns out.
There are going to be lot of
very sad things may happen.
But I want you all to remember.
I'm able to tell you.
Around the world, I've
been speaking with people.
People all over respond
as you did just then.
It's very important for
me be able to tell you
that apparently I'm
speaking pretty much
the way humanity
around the world
would feel it's
reasonable to carry on.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]